[Music]
anytime I need to speak about music I
always have to kind of remind myself
that this this movie is really one story
that it's just being told one time
through normal objective lens and the
other time with this incredible metaphor
of the story in the book once we see
that then it becomes this kind of
constant puzzle with with references
with reflections and so the beginning of
this final moment the final sequence
music starts with the theme which we
hear in the scene when they find the
body so the most sad excruciating moment
and this music in that theme is
incredibly the way we perceive it is
incredibly sorrowful pawneeans and yet
here we start with the very same melody
which has a different meaning to us is
almost optimistic and hopeful and the
way she looks in the mirror is she's
expecting her life will change that
maybe I haven't damaged my life
completely yet and then she touches her
ring and this is were what were the
music starts and in the same way as the
story in the book what we see is is what
she imagines it's not it's not an
objective that the depiction of the
story it's always filtered through her
experience the same way the music at the
ends really reflects everything that we
don't see every stages of her
of her hope turning into this horrible
realization that she's going to be alone
and that she didn't offer the damage
stop the car I came I came out of that
that barbed-wire fence right there right
by the Fletcher
I remember the hell let's get out and
walked and said you walk down right I
came up I came up right here could I
walk along that a Roy over there there's
a fire the old Valdez place the old
cattle station down that way that next
way they'd burn the garbage this road
leads to
[Music]
well I remember with that thing I know
that he you know we're talking about
that setup for that where we you know II
wanted to have it be something that was
very striking and stood out and I
remember there was like some image that
I found with his sofa in the middle of
the forest and it sort of became like a
springboard for that idea with the
cattle station and I know that the you
know that that hole that wall structure
we built in that whole environment we
built so that we could set that up
properly originally I felt it might be a
more violent visual impact and I think
you know Tom's direction to me was
looking quite angelic getting that
matching we have two very different skin
tones I had really gone sort of out on
my own thinking scraped up and dirt and
something very violent and he had said
no and he was really quite right that it
was something quite still and an angelic
and white translucent skin so we did
full body makeup on both our ladies and
I took down the sort of casualty makeup
apart from just that sort of gash of
blood on on ila Tom was really it was
very clever to have that stillness and
quite beautiful for such a disturbing
image I remember even that day when we
were shooting it we it took some time
for him to get them into a position that
he really liked that was it felt that
you know it's everything that we were
doing in that set was very considered
but you still wanted to feel as if that
this is you know so indiscernible
between the two of them right I think
that was one of the things that it
wasn't you weren't sure which was the
daughter and which was the wife and I
think that was something that he was
playing with also a really important
thing to add was this was I think for
most of the crew and certainly the cast
one of the most difficult days and
certainly for both our ladies and for
Jake it was an unbelievably emotionally
ethical day and the whole cast company
we felt in the girls that you it is
difficult sometimes you're doing the
body makeup on a young woman like Ali
and it's indicative of something very
violent and and how we represent that
yes if we all felt it yeah for sure
[Music]
how do you convey what's inside this
character's head because that's the
challenge of nocturnal animals is she is
the nocturnal animal this is her story
her perception that we are witnessing
and it's why amy is just so amazing in
the film because she doesn't actually
have that much dialogue in movie and
most of it is conveyed as a silent movie
actress through her face so it's all
emotional
[Music]
this entire movie takes place in one
character's head
it's her internal monologue that is
going on might become a dialogue in a
way with the audience and the audience
has to feel what she is feeling so it's
she sits down the very beginning she
reads the book that in turn triggered
her to start to remember things in her
past and from her past and also starts
to awaken her there's a lot of talk in
this movie and there's a lot of emphasis
on art she herself feels that she was
supposed to be an artist and that she
abandoned it much like she abandoned
everything that she loved in her life
and at this particular theme that we're
seeing right now comes about half a
little more than halfway in the movie
and she has now started to come alive
and she kind of comes out of her dream
world for a minute and she sees this
painting that is revenge I mean
sometimes you have to be hit in the head
it's what's going on here and she does
she's a character that needed to truly
be hit in the head but she's coming
alive and she's becoming aware of what's
going on and that's when she questions
gentlemen lone character and that
wonderfully ridiculous outfit that she's
wearing where did this painting even
come from basically all the little
things as she's going through this she's
trying to maintain her composure keeping
that outer carapace that she always has
except then when she looks at the phone
everything that about the novel
everything that's about her past comes
back to haunt her
my god it's so cool it's his ass that
lets me watch a willow while she's in
her crib really she's not tractor nanny
no my wife ear I just hate her so and I
would like to be more involved with
Lilith ratification and it sounds
incredible you could actually hear her
breathing and I can talk to her if I
want to are you okay yeah
well you did see someone that's willow
and she's in Akron Amy look it's quite
imperfect in some ways and I think that
was the beauty of what he wanted it's
very hard and makeup for film to do
something that's quite a little bit off
and her skin whiter the hair really
straight at this point and indicative of
the flashbacks where she had a much more
natural look where she's changed her
hair was was naturally wavy to this very
straight poker straight quite affected
look so even the environment is affected
yes like it's very like controlled
that's right right and Jenna Jenna
Malone just came in for this couple of
days with the same say we really stayed
clear of a lot of lip colors but her
with the white face and that red mouth
dress that way Erin's costume and the
set it just all kind of you see their
faces and it does seem to say something
anyways I think we should have cut her
loose she is Assoc sold yourself to be
with me I returned I disagree I think we
should keep her for now - that's because
she's great and we all like her she just
needs our support in a little bit of
time but it's not working we need to
fire her it's an awesome candidate that
we could still see a hammer if we move
fast I agree with Linda we hired her we
should support her new doctor
no new haircut
that's Susan you were the one who
brought it up last meeting that you were
looking for change I know but now I
think we should keep her sometimes
sometimes maybe it's not such a good
idea to change things quite so much Tom
always has a lot of examples how how
music which music who he likes how it
interacts with with a scene but at the
same time it's always a very creative
process really and there is no
theoretical assumption until until it's
done it's never really set in stone as
we continue working on it it turned out
that that certain things could be done
in a different way so what I really love
about this process with Tom is that it's
completely really uncompromised
artistically that we we don't really
commit to anything at the beginning any
choice can be reverted when we realize
that it's not great after all Wells
honor is true to the emotion that we're
trying to do and I think what's so
fascinating about this end scene is that
as an essence a silent movie and the
music that I will composed for the scene
has to take you on this journey through
this last part of the scene when I was a
scene I always think that about moments
when we personally are in a situation
where we are not allowed to show our
emotions outside and on the surface we
can be completely steel and really not
displaying any of what we go through
inside and and yet what's going on
inside is this incredible influx of you
know sometimes adrenaline sometimes
different feelings we can be really
overwhelmed almost puffing out and you
know people around us who wooden
wouldn't even know this
and this seemed I try to imagine if if
Amy tried to act too much to actually
show all this journey in by by her her
acting means it would have been too much
yes it it wouldn't be a release serving
anything and instead she really allowed
an untrusted Tama to to fill this gap at
the end and then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]